bearded right-hander ian anderson dark
hair flipping out of the back of his 70s
era braves cap
and in the air to center a can of corn
for pache who'll drift back to step or
two mccutchen's tagging at first but
he's gonna slam on the brakes and stop
one ball one strike
and harper floats it out to right center
field that'll drop for a base set
mccutcheon he'll stop at second base i
don't know if he read that perfectly
quickly at vega carton two on one out
and alec baum coming up
and he shoots it the opposite way and
basing it to right field mccutcheon's
being held at third
and the bases are now loaded here are
the first inning two balls two strikes
to gegorius
with the bases loaded here in the top of
the first
and he lines one out toward right center
field that's going to drop in for a base
hit one run will score here comes harper
the throw coming to the plate is not in
time
it's a two-run single and the phillies
jump out to a two-nothing lead
and he just took three pitches and is
making a left turn braves bullpen is
working as anderson makes his 30th pitch
and nap chased it
so back-to-back strikeouts the phillies
load the bases and get a hit from didi
gregorius zac eflin 17's last time out
against the brave secret of both sides
of the plate has to be on but it has to
be down in the zone try to get ahead of
the hitters
six rbis and the two two on the way off
the end of the bat down the first base
line a fair ball and that escapes down
the line this will be two bags out of
ronald he's got himself another double
and for acuna it is his third double in
this series
he's now five for six in this series and
he's standing in second base with a lead
off double
so a lead off double for macunia here's
hazy albee's
in the air that's down the right field
line that's going to turn to go
up the fence acuna will score it's a
daily double for ozzy albee's and ronald
lacuna junior and the braves are on the
board let's see if freeman can advance
the runner and get the game tied or
better coming inside to freeman the
pitch
didn't get it there fly ball belted deep
right hartford backpedaling he's going
to turn he's going to say goodbye
if you want to know how to turn on an
inside pitch this is it this ball was
see that coming in and freddie just
pulls the hands in
three balls two strikes
fastball frozen
95 miles an hour and hoskins was looking
for something else anderson's fourth
strikeout
right back where it came from anderson
flagged it down throws a strike to first
let's see if he's all right
that ball got back to the hill in a
hurry
and it's stroked right to freddie
freeman three more up three more down
freyan anderson who has set down eight
phillies in order
did that time though gregorius is down
on strikes
you know that change-up's good when you
know it's coming and you still can't hit
it
swung that time but a soft line drive to
second ten up ten down for anderson
swing and a miss
six strikeouts eleven straight retired
by ian anderson
it's a kind of a devastating loss
grav ball out towards shortstop that
might be too deedy to second for one
super over to first
and in time
a six four three double play
and there are two outs
in the pitch ground ball sharply hit
right at third alec palm up with it
beauty throws it across
and riley is retired real good in this
count with his change up
broken back and on a line to short
12 up 12 down
ground ball sent to short right to
swanson
he stands up and fires end time two down
all right two away that's 13 straight
now retired by anderson one ball no
strikes and the pits swung on hit deep
left field going back and looking up
ozuna and that ball is gone andrew
mccutchen
gets a hold of one of his first home run
of the season he's tied the ball game
here in the fifth inning
it's the little breaking ball that stays
up in the zone and kutch did not miss it
and one of the one mistake that this
young man has made
and he absolutely smoked it to left
center field wow
ian anderson begins the sixth inning
bryce harper leads it off
who would pitch his drill to right field
isn't high enough it is
that's right a solo home run for bryce
harper
and he's just given the phillies the
lead
it's a 4-3 ball game first home run of
the year
game number eight and it was a missile
historically this has been where dansby
has shined at the plate he loves hitting
in these runner and scoring position
situations in the driver's seat here two
balls no strikes
line drive
that's a fair ball
games tied dansby rattles one off the
wall mccutcheon gets to it fast but not
fast enough look at dansby comes through
in a big way and the braves have even
the score
swing and a miss real muto didn't get it
newcomb has his third strikeout
3-2
strike three swung on and missed
way to battle back for sean duke no
behind 3-0 in the cave right back and
got him
they feel very good about that
part of the lineup as adrianza shoots
one the other way
mccutcheon over quickly headache going
for two here comes the throw it's gonna
be late it's a lead off double for
adrianza now freeman's coming up first
and third and one atlanta out
little tapper back to the mound nobody's
covering second throw to the plate
andrianza scores standing up
a little comebacker nobody could get to
the second base bag and alvarado very
casually then realized i got to throw
home and by then it was too late how
about that and will smith looking for
his
second save something to keep an eye on
last time we saw will
we felt like he
got really slider happy
first man up is gene segura the philly
second baseman who had a hit last time
up
and this one dribbled toward third
reilly charges throws on the run one
pitch one out we'll take a couple more
of those
as smith gets the sign here it is swing
and a miss struck him out
let's find out together shall we here it
is
line drive center poche broke in breaks
back and he got it
the braves win tonight they win the
series
in a thrilling ball game 5-4 your final